[Musique]
combien croyez-vous qu'il y ait deux pas
plus cher
vous trompez pas voter bien sûr
photowatt
hoarau claude attention il nous manque
un
[Musique]
quoi tu as encore grossi pâte à tarte
maintenant on pense encore marchi qui ne
pourra bientôt plus passer par la porte
qui accueille dans ses casseroles bonnes
galettes de pommes de terre
nous allons nous régaler des pommes de
terre tu vas prendre 30 il d'un coup tu
vais les prendre
hier pâte a ajouté pat aclu aussi ont
droit aussi
ils mangent trop à partir d'aujourd'hui
régine résume tu vas maigri et faire de
la gymnastique comme tout le monde je
vais chercher mon livre de vaisseau de
gymnastique et mes galettes qui sont si
bonnes pâtes accord est folle de gros
six mois évidemment je ne suis pas
maigre progrès gros du tout peut-être
même un petit peu ronde
bon on va migrer au négoce avec lui en
gros voilà pour aujourd'hui ou pour
demain
[Musique]
on aura tout d'un coup tout en place les
relations n'avaient les bras baissés les
pieds à lens est contraire baissé les
bras levés les pieds alors enfin comment
bien le son côté sur points et arte
libre à la gymnastique 125 moi aussi et
moi non
silence dans l'hérault
thacker de toujours première des
attentes pour le temps deux autres et
maintenant haut ce qu'une crise presque
tous en course à pied
attac loup fait le tour de la maison
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
m
je suis comme neuf
maintenant nous allons déjà mais clame a
donné fans vous faire faire de la
gymnastique
pourquoi tu as le cherche les fameuses
galettes aux pommes de terre impossible
impossible tu es trop fatigué peut-être
alors pas hésité à y aller n'est pas ta
vue n'est personne au nom ont fait en
régime on ne le fait pas
j'ai jeté mes galets d'ailleurs personne
à faire ici tu as un pata cloud mois du
tour pat asus
moi non plus alors c'est parfait tu dois
être content pas tiger
tout le monde va maigrir même toit
[Musique]
et bien croyez vous qu'il y ait de pâte
à pêcher ne faut trop écope beauté bien
sûr votre attention
il me manque
[Musique]